[Music]
we just came of parison movement where
we shattered our online viewer ship
records what do you think the
Grantchester is doing for the popularity
of chess the general audience for the
most part do not really watch like a six
hour eight hour game right now it's it's
too long so the introduction of fast
test 10-minute games one hour games has
been interesting this in that case
people can can follow each game and also
brings a level of excitement when
there's a lot of coverage of rapid and
blitz in particular with the bunch of
decisive results there tend to be there
tends to be much more interest in trust
and so I think that's probably why both
Paris and moving had such a big amount
of people watching online rapid and
blitz events in the grand gesture I
think are very exciting to follow and
this year the time delay makes it
slightly even more unpredictable because
we're actually losing on time and it's
uncomfortable for the players I think
but it makes it much more fun for the
spectator the Chess Club is always
innovating only 20 new which brings us
to a wider audience so I can go in I
think I was growing future but already
there's normal colors I think the four
markets are not professional and it's
not a surprise that you know you worship
increased of course and the interest of
chests has increased dramatically in the
last few years of course reporting back
and get more touch to it it has a left
teste comment I in the world so it
introduces new people to watch the
videos you need good product to bring
people to chest and I think generally
the whole organization is doing a good
job properly promoting chest - - in
particular the internet audiences a very
very large part of what we should be
trying to achieve so the tour is a you
know very very serious step and whether
[Music]